early this morning elon musk the world's
richest man went to twitter and
challenged vladimir putin to a fight i'm
not kidding literally he tweeted i
hereby challenge vladimir putin to
single combat the stakes are ukraine now
elon musk is known for tweeting all
kinds of insane crazy hilarious things
but this just may top everything else
he's ever tweeted we have the world's
richest man
now challenging a world leader who has
engaged in violent combat and invaded
ukraine ultimately everyone on the
internet thought that elon musk was
joking but he followed it up a couple of
minutes later where he said to the
kremlin do you agree to this fight and
when you start to think about the idea
that elon musk is publicly calling out
vladimir putin and the kremlin you just
gotta wonder how much crazier can 2022
get but of course as more and more
people piled into the comments and asked
elon whether he was serious or not
here's exactly what he said he said if
putin could so easily humiliate the west
then he would accept the challenge but
he will not i don't know where we go
from here but i know that we have the
world's richest man
challenging a dictator of russia to a
physical combat fight i would pay a lot
of money to watch this play out i don't
know who would win putin's been studying
judo for 50 plus years and elon musk i
don't know he's just got a lot of cash
and he seems like a big dude who maybe
would just fight for the honor of the
west that's all i got for you let's see
if it'll end up happening hey you did
you like this video great we make five
of them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time